اعزائي المواطنين اعتبارا من الساعه
الثالثه صباحا اليوم وفي جميع انحاء تركيا
تولت القوات المسلحه التركيه اداره شؤون
البلاد
[موسيقى]
اشتاق الى الصبا والى مدينتي
ليتني ما تركتها وعملت بالسياسه
[موسيقى]
اول من اكتشف قدرات عدنان مندرس السياسيه
كان مؤسس الدوله التركيه اتاتورك تعرف على
عدنان مندريس وقد اكتشف خلال المقابله
تاثير ماندرس وعلمه وحب الناس له وبالتالي
دعاه للانضمام لحزب الشعب الجمهوري
[موسيقى]
كان الحزب الديمقراطي كحزب معارض في تلك
الفتره يتسم بالليبراليه حيث كانوا ضد
موقف حزب الشعب الجمهوري من تدخل الدوله
في المجال الاقتصادي ومؤيدين لنموذج
اقتصاد السوق وذلك في الملف الاقتصادي اما
في الملف السياسي فكانوا ضد مواقف حزب
الشعب السلطويه وداعمين لحريه الراي وما
يتعلق بها لذلك استطاع الحزب الحصول على
التاييد والشعبيه الواسعه من الناس وايضا
تاييد ودعم من الكتله الليبراليه
والمحافظه ومن المفكرين في تركيا
[موسيقى]
تشعر الناس لاول مره بوجود حزب يقف في
صفهم على حساب النخبه ويعمل لصالحهم هم
ويهتم بشؤونهم وبفكره المواطنه
اللهم صل
على سيدنا محمد وعلى
[موسيقى]
من حيث انجازاته الماديه فقام بانشاء بعض
البنوك وبدا نهضه في مجال الانشاءات
والتوسع العمراني انما التركي بنسبه 160%
خلال فتره حكم الحزب الديمقراطي من حيث
اقامه السجود والطرق والكباري والماء
والكهرباء والتصنيع في كل المجالات ظهرت
تنميه كبرى فقط هناك جانب واحد اهمله من
دريس وهو الجانب الديمقراطي
[موسيقى]
تم تاسيس لجنه التحقيقات وكان هدف هذه
اللجنه التحقيق مع بعض الصحفيين واعضاء من
حزب الشعب الجمهوري المعارض بمعنى ان
الديمقراطيه في تركيا كانت تشهد حاله من
الاستقطاب الشديد والتوتر
[موسيقى]
نحن لا نريد ثوره هذا الطريق شديد الخطوره
غيرنا يمكن ان يقوم بهذا الامر ذلك كان
تلخيصا لخطبه قام بها عصمه اينونو زعيم
المعارضه في البرلمان كان يقول عصمت
اينونو ان كوريا الجنوبيه حدث فيها انقلاب
وكان يقول الحزب الديمقراطي ان الطريق
الذي تسيرون فيه خاطئ ولا يبشر بالخير
فليشه التركي ليس اقل شرفا من كوريا
الجنوبيه في الحقيقه هنا دعوه للجيش لكي
يقوم بانقلاب ويقول له اذا كان الجيش
يستطيع القيام بانقلاب فليقوموا به
تولت القوات المسلحه التركيه اداره شؤون
البلاد هذه العمليه قد نجحت دون خسائر في
الارواح بفضل التعاون الوثيق بين
المواطنين وقوات الامن ولهذا قد تم فرض
حظر التجوال الى اشعار اخر
[موسيقى]
وصلت الطائرات العسكريه للقرى وبداوا
يوزعون المنشورات والجرائد ويقولون الظالم
ذهب الخائن ذهب يقصدون بذلك مندرس وقد
جئنا لكم بالحريه ورايت بنفسي كيف كان
موقف الجيش ولكن الشعب لم يتقبل ذلك حيث
راى ان الاستبداد والظلم فقط انتقل من
سلطه الحكومه لسلطه الجيش الحاكم الجديد
لم يوافق الشعب على ذلك ابدا ولكن اظهر
رفضه في الانتخابات التاليه عام
اقصد ان المواطن التركي اعطى صوته للاحزاب
السائره على منهاج الحزب الديمقراطي
والمكمله له بنسب كبيره من وجهه نظري انه
في الطريق الانقلاب 1960 كان مقررا القيام
به سواء قام مندرس باخطاء ام لا قبل
الانقلاب بيومين في احد المؤتمرات
الجماهيريه في مدينه اسكشهير اعلن مندرس
عن عقد انتخابات مبكره بعد شهرين لم تكتب
صحف المعارضه عن الخبر ابدا
تم بث جو من الارهاب في المجتمع
في ظل مناخ كهذا من يقوم ليعلو صوته ضد ما
حدث راى قسم من الناس وتحديدا القسم
التابع لحزب الشعب ان الانقلاب نصر وانقاذ
لهم حتى ان بعض اعضاء من الحزب تعاونوا مع
الجيش للابلاغ عن اعضاء الحزب الديمقراطي
ومساعدتهم في التعرف على اماكن سكنهم
للقبض عليهم لذلك خسر حزب الشعب الجمهوري
بدرجه كبيره بعده
[موسيقى]
هل يسي ادا تعتبر محاكمه لا ليست كذلك بل
هي مراسم اعدام تم انشاؤها بهدف سياسي
[موسيقى]
في العاده كان يشبه حلبه السرك المحيطة
بالجمهور الذي جاء يشاهد الحيوانات في
الحلبه كان يجلس مجموعه من القضاه وعلى
راسهم باشول وكان يقوم بالتهكم عليهم بشكل
مستمر وفقا لهواه وكان الجمهور يضحك على
تلك التهكمات باصوات عاليه
ويحقرون من المتهمين
[موسيقى]
ايام كانت شديده الصعوبه والعداله كانت
غائبه في ذلك اليوم في احد الايام جلسنا
واعددنا مدافعه مشتركه عن المتهمين وقمنا
بقراءتها لم يستمعوا حتى لدقيقه واحده
لشهود الدفاع والمتهمين
[موسيقى]
قرار الاعدام اراه انتقاما من مندرس
لقيامه بعزل بعض الجنرالات والضباط قبل
ذلك اتى الانقلاب بسلبيه سياسيه لان
الحصول على اصوات ناخبين ليس كافيا ولا
يحل شيئا في تركيا السلطه الحقيقيه موجوده
في مكان اخر تلك السلطه تستطيع بصافره ان
توقف المباراه وتقوم بتغيير الفريقين ثم
البدء من جديد وتقوم بتخطيط المباراه حتى
يحصل على النتيجه التي يريدها انا لست
مساء منكم وكذا اقول لمن يمسك بالخيوط
ويتحكم في الامر وانا اعرفه جيدا هؤلاء
ايضا لست مستاءا منهم بل اشكرك انهم
امهلوني 17 عاما اخرى ولم يقوموا بقتلي
والتخلص مني عندما انسحبت من حزب الشعب
الجمهوري حيث يوجد سبب جدي يجعلهم
يعدمونني
[موسيقى]
وحري بكم الا تخافوا من حياتي اما الان
وبعد اعدام ماندريس سيقوم الشعب بتعقب
فعلتكم وسيحاكمكم التاريخ على ذلك ويمحوا
اسمائكم ورغم ذلك انا اسامحكم على فعلتكم
[موسيقى]